[Music]
let's finish up Disney cember with
descendants - well if you saw my first
review you know I'm not exactly a big
fan of this big surprise but sometimes
it could be enjoyed in a so bad it's
good kind of way this one is bad in a
very different way a strange way and
that's saying a lot seeing how this is
already a strange movie series is it
better worse it's kind of hard to say on
the surface the plot seems exactly what
you think it would be the descendants
are still living among the do-gooders
but they're completely reformed which is
weird seeing how the opening song is
bragging about how wicked they are and
all the bad things they're doing and
then immediately after it's like that
never happened yeah we're so bad we're
so mean we're outlaws Oh time to act
like the good students that we are what
the hell is the point of that musical
number in fact our lead character Mel is
kind of getting tired of being so good
for new upper-crust status and now being
in a relationship with Prince Ben gets
her thinking maybe the old wicked days
were better than they thought and
speaking of which C which that is the
daughter of Ursula named uma is pissed
off at her and her villain friends are
still stuck on the evil Island while all
the other goody two-shoes get to live in
harmony so she has a plan to trick mal
into handing over the fairy godmothers
magic wand to get him off forever
when the descendants tried to stop this
they kidnapped Ben and hold him hostage
unless they turn the wand over it's a
thrilling fight / dance / wrap off
resulting in a colorful climax where the
descendents save the day
well Baron is nothing special but wait a
minute there's still a half hour left
but that's a perfect place to stop why
are you still going you defeated the
villain save the guy went back home what
else is there to do well yeah this is
where the movie gets a little stranger
than usual a good chunk of the movie is
just sitting around and talking not
necessarily bad stuff talking about
emotions where you belong all sorts of
teen angst but this is the movies over
isn't it an hour and a half that's a
decent run time you defeated the fellow
why are we still going this build-up
eventually results in another climax one
not nearly as good as
the first one and kind of disjointed
even the message is kind of all over the
place it's about not judging a book by
it's cover but then this one person
seems evil but then they're not then
they are evil again and there's some
really bad effects and even then they
don't really utilize that because they
just kind of talk it out again even
though it's promising something big and
even that's kind of a half-ass
resolution but who cares we have a dance
scene at the end that's all that seems
to matter what the hell did I just watch
this movie is all over the map and I'd
be lying if I said it was worth getting
angry at because it's descendants - I
didn't even get that much into the first
one the elements that work in it are the
same elements that worked in the first
one the dance sequences are really good
the sets and costumes are colorful and
again you got to give credit to a dumb
idea actually taking time to analyze the
characters having them talk having them
actually discuss their problems and the
good problems like I said figuring out
your emotions where you belong all sorts
of teen stuff but that's not especially
riveting because these kids still have
to be marketable they still have to be
pretty they still have to be just blank
enough for you to insert yourself into
their role
you're the good-looking dancer you're
the one going through troubles you're
the one that has the boy or girl that
has the hots for you
and because of this the actors are not
really allowed to explore what they can
do with the characters so yeah on the
one hand there's not as many bad things
as the first one there's no villain
sitting around in a room acting like an
old folks home or anything like that but
at the same time why even have it
connected to the Disney Villains it
seems like there's no point the Disney
villains are some of the great cinematic
characters and to not really make that
much of a connection to them just has me
asking why'd you do it to begin with so
is it good no but again like the other
one it's pretty hard less I can see kids
watching it and enjoying it and there's
nothing really bad in it for them and
there are surprisingly attempts at good
ideas in there like I said trying to
have character development the good
dancing and so forth but the majority of
it is pretty dull if you weren't a fan
of the first one this one's definitely
not gonna sway you it's not wave your
fists anger inducing but it doesn't
leave an impact either which some would
say could be worse if you liked the
first one you probably like this one
fine if not then just leave bad enough
then that's about it for this year's
Disney cember my thoughts
well Inc it's like any Disney cember
there were some good ones and there were
some bad ones the good ones weren't
amazing or mind-blowing but they were
very enjoyable and the bad ones yeah
they were bad nevertheless it is neat to
see a series of movies that different
generation grew up with it's kind of
interesting to see what people younger
than me made popular and if what they
made popular still holds up I'm happy to
see that some of them do it's nice to
know that when a series of movies is
trying to be manipulative it can't be
manipulative in the right way it can
teach good lessons it can open up the
imagination it can teach kids about
character and story it just also happens
to be selling toys and clothes and
soundtracks and so forth I had a lot of
fun this Disney cember and I hope you
did too hopefully I'll see you next year
and until then keep that disney
imagination sorry
[Music]
you